you know made 49 year-old men do not
believe in themselves yep post you got
your prospective
so guess one of the things we want to
hit on is women entrepreneurs' Angeles
I've owned our own business now for
seven years we're together and we are a
partnership and we actually still really
like each other
not to like each other even more than we
did when we begin that means you guys
are communicating we communicate more
than I sometimes communicate with my
husband makes a lot of sense her husband
gets really jealous and you have to
write yeah business you know a lot of
people that are confused about
entrepreneurs they don't realize that
the business is the other family member
so true I mean it just is like business
is another child another spouse it is
it's intense like you know it's it's the
output of people's passion it's hot I
look at businesses more like friends you
know like you don't you know you don't
get to choose who you're born into as
parents or siblings but you do pick your
friends and a lot of times that's why
those are the most meaningful
relationships you do get to pick your
business you do and you create this
culture right and you create this family
like we have our theory family that is
our staff it's our spouses
it's our coach it's everybody and it
could we have this culture and it's our
clientele like it's not just selling to
us it's creating this lifestyle that
people that we love not only that when
you then start breaking down how many
hours you work it's not work I get that
and that's why it's working yeah but you
start cutting down how much time you
work on you're not work or your work or
your business or your product and you
start realizing my god my profession my
career my passion you know if you're
lucky enough like you guys are is the
majority of what I spend my time on yes
and and I think that's why I'm so
passionate about communicating my points
of view on what the Internet has created
oh you know looking at the five of us
none of us were born into a world where
this much opportunity existed our
parents and grandparents did not have
this opportunity no I just did it now
the Internet is like electricity it's
not running water and I don't think
we've understood that and electricity
and running water led to like better
quality of life day to day the Internet
it's the happiness if you choose to
harness it oh I never sent it's a big
deal but it's not hard to teach that you
can be happy right you can go outside of
those extremes they have a bet on
yourself buddy was taught to go to
school and stay within a system what
about a woman you were taught to be a
mom right and stayed at home and that's
a huge thing that we push back in our
small community cuz Angela's a mom I'm
not and I've chosen to run the business
you have kids she's chosen to be a
working mom yes can I have that you know
struggle right yeah I think you know
both of you probably have that struggle
like I think that struggle oh yeah I
think I think like as soon as you guys
as soon as you were just saying that I'm
like oh that's good what I meant why I
said that's good in my head is I'm a
very big believer that if you see
anybody in your circumstance succeed and
happiness forget about money well then
you can too you know like if there's
anybody out there who's born into two
parents that were addicted to heroin and
we're never around and that person went
on to achieve happiness then every child
who sees that person can point to that I
think it's very powerful to be
cofounders one who does have a family
and one who doesn't because your
audience then gets to see themselves in
one of you and so I think that's that's
incredible very obvious question that is
how do we get that out more our sort of
story because I don't I think we
struggle every single day with our
business their content but we do attend
a continued
because it's the actual answer and like
even take this right you're filming this
yes I see that I see this as in my mind
in that free deck that I put out right
the guarantee content model I see today
right now as 34 pieces of content really
there's the fun that's right that is the
answer yeah you know is easily yeah like
that great and the fact that you
answered so easily that means you guys
are halfway home now it's just execution
and maybe you're doing that - I don't
know but I can tell you that up until I
put out that deck until I started
getting loud about how I do the content
a lot of podcasters 99% of them see this
as one piece of content oh no II
understand yeah he pushes us over there
to do that and so the answer is more I
mean it's like you know how do you get
bigger muscles you work more lose more
fat you workout more how do you how do
you get your heart healthier you do that
you know like like the answer is more I
was saying something to Brandon my best
friend who runs Wine Library now who I
built my library with who I've known
since I was 14 doing baseball cards and
I said something to him this is a true
story this happened only a couple hours
ago I was telling him about my ambitions
for him as an executive at Wine Library
and why I think we can be way more
successful next year and I set them
something pretty powerful that I never
really articulated I said Brandon you
know the guy that you worked with those
12 years the one that you admire and
think is the best I currently in my
current form
as a business man as a person as a
father a husband a man I view that guy
that was me only a decade ago and I
referenced the former employee of ours
who was like a c-minus and it really
took him back and it's actually the
truth I can't believe how much better I
am today then I was 10 years ago and I
thought I was the best 10 years ago you
can imagine one of the things that I'm
most proud of is I only give advice I
took over the last 10 years I've become
better there's nothing else to say I've
become better how do you become better
it's maybe the main question one step at
a time your ear it's your
I really she was very very basic very
easy to understand you said how do we
get our message out more yeah my answer
was more content yeah yeah you have a
podcast wait I want you to transcribe
this interview into a LinkedIn post I
want you to write a medium post I want
you to have your own blog on your
website I want you take seven quotes
from this interview and put pictures
over it I want you to take seven clips
and put on Facebook I want you to put it
on YouTube I want you to put three
one-minute cool ups from this on YouTube
like I want you to make an infographic
of what I'm saying right now of like how
we're gonna make more content chart I
mean more more more more MORE how do you
find the time like oh I know you're
working for free or getting paid I you
buy time yes you buy time yeah
leveraging correct yeah you buy time
well that's exactly what we did with
them comes right see them because it's
kind of like a dream of them and Camilo
loves you so we that is the way we've
always done our business it's not about
us know who we can bring with us on the
journey and and that becomes a selfless
act that is selfish because it makes you
happy yes I understand me too
like the four-minute conversation with
Jason yesterday like makes me pumped
right like getting so close to Seth and
seeing him get engaged last week like
like to me I genuinely get happiness
from other people getting happy mainly
cuz I'm pretty emotionally fulfilled yes
once you're happy what the only logical
next step is to make other people happy
there is no more so I get it but the
answer is you have to make your actions
map your ambitions so I have no idea how
big you want to be big great so then
basically happy so you basically have to
leave short term vanity things because
if you want to be big then you have to
make sacrifices did you let go of
control for that to have a new person
and that's a difficult thing if you talk
to my team right now they'll tell you
the level of
autonomy that I give them creatively and
process wise is take you to get to that
point
I've always been basically in that point
because that was a natural strength of
mine realizing practically see the
interesting thing about me that I don't
talk a whole lot about is I would argue
that I'm disproportionately more
practical than I am emotional and people
are confused by that because I'm so high
energy and I'm so vibed out yeah that it
disguises my level of practicality I
haven't been able to build these 8200
million dollar businesses out of
charisma it's been operational so very
quickly I realized scale came in
ninety-eight people doing a seven of my
ten versus one person doing a ten it's
not really hard if you're fortunate
enough to not have ego yeah I mean it
and honestly and honestly it's a fun
thing to say mainly because it you know
ego is just insecurity disguise
I felt ran so but listen you'll
appreciate this I have empathy it's you
know the hardest thing to let go is the
image of oneself yeah you know it's one
thing if you're letting go how people
stock your shelves at a liquor store
which I did which my dad couldn't yeah
or a million other things I've let go
the most valuable thing of all they are
actually 100% in control of my image I
love it I mean I do not micro man it's
absurd when you think about the level
here's why I believe the truth always
wins so if Seth went rogue
I mean Seth tomorrow could not leave he
could literally record the first two
minutes of the podcast and be like hey
guys is Seth let me actually tell you
the truth about Gary but like but but I
would never know there is no checks and
balances I blindly trust Seth yeah
mainly because I know who I actually am
the reason I'm not scared is every
mistake is fixable when the truth and
good is on your side hundred percent
I totally believe that every
we had yeah and we actually went down
really good places yeah going instead of
breathing out yeah do being the bigger
person yeah yeah is always the move yeah
and I had to be I made a huge mistake
it's funny to reminder each day in every
moment to be that person and I learned
from it
and let me tell you this the world
doesn't get upset at you for a mistake
it get its upset of you for the cover-up
yes and she phoned the client told him
the truth I was like I'm so sorry and
she's like Angela I thought honestly
something bad was happening I'm like I
did I forgot to order your chairs she's
like no that's not a mistake it's just
like it's not the end of the world Mike
to me it because it was my ego cuz I
don't you're safe but you own I own the
mistake I hundreds on own and she's okay
not everybody's gonna own the mistake
you didn't own it right away that's why
you had to get into that part right well
um I was shocked I was like sure yeah
cuz I was 100% shocked I actually I was
like oh my god I mean I basically lived
my life
expecting to make substantial mistakes
on a daily basis
mainly because humans are flawed I mean
the biggest problem with our society
right now is hypocrisy all we do is
deploy judgment on others while we're
doing something else that's wrong and I
think we find as females that we judge
each other even more so when you talk
about like being a mom and working or me
not having kids I'm just I mean honestly
you'll appreciate this I've looked at
that issue a little bit demure eásá t
it's a bear it's a very big issue and I
think it's a proper reaction from women
in our society because I I as a white
male come from a place of abundance I
don't think there's limited spots women
do Oh women are lead to you because
you're always competing for that number
one spot
number one spot for that only spot
amongst all the other spots because only
one woman can fill it yeah eight guys
and so you know I have a lot of empathy
to how women got there I'm just hopeful
that the next century it will dissolve
over time I hope so I hope I instill
that into my daughter that you know
don't be don't judge other women you
know just don't judge anybody don't
judge anybody that's right now on
judgment and be happy just so angry and
I don't get angry I'm angry at people's
ability to judge
with deep levels of hypocrisy on the
back end yeah I am I am sure of the
following statement every person I've
ever seen in society has done things
that they're not proud of
Oh hundred percent yeah I know it yes
everybody is thus they they're lying
thus I don't have the capability of
judging somebody else's life I don't
know what's going on in their bedroom in
their house in their head in their
relationship
I just hate judge I'm crippled by
judgment I hand it I want to eliminate
it yeah I feel the same way you know as
meditation has become a big thing in our
culture I've I don't meditate but I kind
of live a very thoughtful mindful
spiritual macro intriguing mindset life
I'm I often say that I live in a cocoon
I go to myself you got em self-soothing
you know it's funny yeah when you asked
that question I literally thought about
a cat licking itself never used this
analogy ever I know my team has never
heard this I don't this is true I don't
know why cats licked them I guess that's
how they made themselves yeah I would
tell you that I do a mental version of
that I am within myself I am NOT in need
of an outside or or other force to
navigate what's going on in my life I've
also never experienced the death of
somebody disproportionately close to me
because I lost all my grandparents
except for one and didn't have a very
large family so here I am at 43 years
old and not losing my parents siblings
children spouse so you know I'm maybe
gonna need it then the only thing I
really do care about is those 11 12 13
people like I wish people actually knew
how real that is to me I think people
say it and they're not truthful yeah I
think people say all I care about is my
family but then I watch their actions
that's not true I don't go to anybody I
go to myself that's amazing
I do I got myself in my sleep in my
showers in my flights in those moments
where I have a second to myself where
I'm not workin every second I go to
myself that's amazing I'm jealous
and honestly a lot of what I'm trying to
put into the world is trying to get
people into that lately I've been doing
you know at a keynote recently yeah I've
been doing this kind of like I've only
done this shtick now a couple times
where I put my fingers in my ears I'm
like my happiness comes from this you
know I can't hear anybody you know when
you can't hear anybody for real and I
want to really go here right now I'm not
gonna even hear your wife and your ear
hear my wife Gary I don't and it's funny
you went there and that's where I was
about to go in its truth in its purest
form when you don't hear your spouse or
your parents or your children that's it
that's why I am Who I am I don't hear it
really tight ways to get to its yeah
because it feels like you're everybody
always wants something from you so
you're basically like especially you
you're probably pulled in like a million
different directions guys I mean I look
I think I have a unique life for a
reason I really do know that oh yeah I
do know that like I don't have this
admiration or success or notoriety or
the thing that's happening with me is
the byproduct of Who I am a couple
things back to ego and security cops and
all that stuff
hey I don't think I did that I think
Gary Vee is the byproduct of tomorrow
and Sasha Vaynerchuk the byproduct of
capitalism in America like the byproduct
of a kid who was born with nothing and
had to earn his keep
so like that so like when people like
when when this nice feelings that I'm
getting from you guys come you'd be so
surprised how much that doesn't go to me
which keeps me disproportionate grounded
that's how you don't have an ego
that's exactly right exactly you know
and it's like I have confidence
confident ones yeah but I have such
disproportionate amounts of humility
because I'm aware of the truth which is
I
have less to do with this I think people
confused that there's a byproduct of
much more than they are I think their
children their businesses like my pride
in my children and definitely my
businesses will be very high because
that's me architecting yeah my community
I'm very proud of the positivity and
positivity with with non delusion is
very difficult to create I don't want to
be the secret you know I don't even want
to be you know Tony Robbins or Oprah
I've got a different kind of slight gear
to it which comes with a level of
practicality and accountability and lack
of entitlement that is a little bit
different and I do think that's why it's
happening but it's very quiet in my head
very very very quiet
I am disproportionately not anxious
yes anxiety has grown in our society I'm
less anxious than I've ever been
well I didn't sleep last night I was so
excited me but but worrying doesn't come
natural to me because I feel in control
and here's where being quiet helps I'm
so comfortable if I make 13 bad business
decisions lose everything every article
on earth is written see I told you he
was full of [ __ ] he wasn't good he
wasn't as good as he thought this is why
don't be the next Gary Vee as a headline
that doesn't bother me I'll tell you why
number one if I go on to lose everything
from a business standpoint I deserve
those headlines number two I don't care
because I feel capable of coming back
and then I get to rise like a phoenix
and then do it all again and so I think
being quiet in your head is a big deal
I'm not worried about who thinks I'm
ugly or stupid or full of [ __ ] or not
capable or not as good as I think I just
I know it's funny I respect it I hear it
but I don't consume it
I definitely don't internal I
it and I don't live my life predicated
on it so you gonna be teaching license
on yeah you know what I think I'm doing
it you are you really are because I
listen do I look like we listened to all
your like podcasts and YouTube and
everything in it Kent has completely
changed and I think yeah and before I
say something I think with the
comparison or the judgment or getting
upset when Angela miss it makes a
mistake at work it's usually take a
couple of minutes it makes like you
don't even like I wish there was data on
the chemicals that are going through my
body when I listen to you cuz I believe
you and let me tell you something
as you continue to go through the
process it's bonkers it's just oh it
just gets better and better and better
makes it her feels so much better
because you're not bringing home all
that negativity like if I get upset at
work I don't want to bring it home so I
don't want to I even have it at work no
because people are with us all day
you're also like once you start actually
letting go and realize you weren't in
control of it anyway you're never yeah
yeah it's like I'm not in you know why I
get full autonomy what am I gonna sit on
Seth's head and watch what he does
that's why I have scale you want to
build something big
it's about fundamentally letting go of
everything except the 1% of things that
matter which are your actions
nature and we've learned that now cuz we
have weights in all 80s there's eight
there's 10 of us that work together all
ladies and we get along like a family
yeah which is very rare makes me really
happy it means that in the beginning and
I'm saying it towards the end now it's
communication oh it's empathy it's
kindness it's gratitude
it's these soft skills and look for me
the most exciting thing that's happening
in my life which is a very similar thing
to what's going on with you but I don't
think people see it as obviously with me
so you guys must be disproportionate
sensit proud about the impact you're
having on female entrepreneurship and
happiness yeah I think an underlining
thing that I don't see I don't think
people are realizing what I'm actually
up to when I tell you the level of pride
I have that I'm rewiring 15 to 25 year
old alpha males and making things that
have never been cool to alpha men
all like empathy like kindness like
gratitude that is very far away from
bottles and models and hooking up and
money and private I mean the stark
difference between what these kids are
getting from me on my Instagram feed
versus what they're getting from almost
everybody else the level of impact that
I will have on society if I pull this
off to the level that I think I'm
pulling it off with you well it's
remarkable because there's very few
people that are capable to penetrate a
17 year old kid for that kid to think
that that person is cool to change their
mindset that then stuffs them once they
think that person's cool with propaganda
of being a kind and awesome human being
so true and I think Gary for us what we
want to do is do the exact same thing
but with females especially females that
maybe have been mothers stay at home for
18 years and then their kids leave and
they don't know who they are and they've
never done anything with their life
because we see a lot of people right now
that are nice and you know what's my
sauce and what's amazing when you say
that sentence what just transpired on it
I see you Tyler about to leave and it's
a great way to end i as an operator and
I know this is not how you meant it so
but I want to tell you what just
happened in my brain 18 years never did
anything with their life you're talking
about professional versus you know I'm
not I know I know I know I know that's
why I hedged it up like these skills to
manage one to four children very
different cuz you love them in a
different way than your employees but
give me a 52 year-old woman who quickly
went into motherhood and navigated that
dynamic I believe the current landscape
of business which is becoming
disproportion more in emotional
intelligence yes then skills women from
the 50s 60s 70s what we all grew up with
now when the world in the 60s 70s 80s
90s were vocational when the skill was
the value yes well then one would say
woof that's tough you now have to learn
craft at 49 I believe we have now
entered a world where emotional
intelligence and management is the most
valuable disproportionate when you think
of the comps of running a family as a
mother there is an enormous bandwidth
and capability of juggling a lot of
emotions at one time I think we're gonna
see the golden era of women that are
gonna be able to have their cake and eat
it too that starts right about now but
they have to learn to believe in
themselves fear straight answer well
they don't have the courage you'll
appreciate this that's for every single
human being on earth oh yeah you know
you know me 49 year old men do not
believe in themselves yep most so in the
macro of course but the belief got us
here with you today sitting here Friday
babe hundred-percent relief every Friday
you a babe like she's our babe and we're
supporting babes it's the thing so
you're bait or are they Friday am i I'm
not in the office front we're gonna take
a picture with you this is amazing
amazing
let's do it let's go model I saw thank
you so much hope you got it for the wall
wall wall
alright guys I just pull in my camera